- Epic day, iconic day.
Moving offices.
Hey, you getting ready?
Look how much shit
there still is here.
Look at Trouty.
I'm gonna miss 12 so much.
You ready for Hudson Yards?
You guys seem to be
working really hard in the move.
Guys, I want my office
to be awesome on Monday.
That's it.
(light music)
Yeah, actually Jordan
brought that up today.
He's like Tyler
wants to get in a lift.
I go I love that people
think it's some
sort of random thing you do.
- [Tyler] No, I've
been working out a lot.
- [Gary] I got to tell you
I could never work out if
I didn't have a person.
- [Tyler] Have a person?
And what I did today.
You couldn't pay me to do.
You couldn't pay me to do it.
I wore white pants.
- [Tyler] I saw that
when you walked in.
I'm like cool, man.
- Yeah, dude on a very serious
note let's get shit hung.
- [Tyler] Cool.
- Bring the crew.
Bring four people.
Andy?
- [Tyler] We're gonna work
out of there tomorrow
and get it all done.
- [Gary] I want my office
to be awesome on Monday.
- Yeah?
- I have 44 people on my team
and I'm gonna walk in Monday and
I'm going to go in a box
with a nothing set up.
My office should be
fucking pristine.
I should have a fucking orchid.
I should walk in and it should
be, it should be done already,
it should be gorgeous.
I'm the CEO this
fucking company.
I'm gonna walk in
like a piece of shit.
Guys, I want my office to be
awesome on Monday and
I feel like it's
not going to be.
And I feel like there's 74
people on my team and
so can we figure this out?
By the way, I checked these
things but you guys could've
went through stuff.
Nobody did anything good for me.
Nobody does good
stuff for me, guys.
I feel like I do
all the good stuff.
Emily, do you think it's
appropriate that my office is
going to be shit on Monday?
- [Emily] What are
you talking about?
- Like nothing good
was gonna happen.
I was going to walk into--
- Your office is beautiful.
- [Gary] No, no in theory.
- No it is.
- [Gary] Not setup.
No, no there's nothing in there.
- Oh, you have the best views.
You have two beautiful--
- [Gary] Emily, I paid
for those views.
(laughter)
Tyler, tell the truth
'cause you always do.
That's what I love about
you always say yes and no.
Would the office be unbelievably
cozy on Monday had
I not said something?
- Yes.
- [Gary] Unbelievably?
- Unbelievable.
- I feel like it was
not going to be cozy.
But I trust, I trust that Tyler
doesn't lie so I guess
I gotta go with it.
Sup?
- [Man] Hey.
- [Woman] Oh sorry.
- [Gary] Oh sorry.
- [Woman 2] Hey.
- [Gary] Hey.
Look at this.
Skye, Skye?
You're on Periscope,
you're obviously very in
charge of this big move.
- Yes.
- [Gary] Are we under control?
Are we ready?
- We are.
We're like totally ready.
- [Gary] You got this?
- I got this. We're good.
- [Gary] You sure?
- Yep.
- [Gary] Look at Trouty.
Put together
seven boxes already.
I'm impressed.
Oh, my office.
This is it.
Hey Linds.
- [Linds] Hi. How's it going?
- [Gary] Good.
- [Man 2] 'Sup Gary?
- [Gary] 'Sup guys?
This is it, huh?
- [Tyler] Yo.
- [Gary] Yo.
- [Tyler] I'm changing
your cell phone number.
- [Gary] What's that?
- [Tyler] Changing
your cell phone number.
- What the hell
you talking about?
I mean everybody's
getting a little bit, (sighs)
- [Tyler] I agree.
- Everybody's getting a
little too ridiculous.
- [Tyler] I get it. I agree.
- [Gary] I know I'll be the most
famous person in the world but
I'm not yet.
'Sup guys?
- [Woman 3] Hi Gary.
- [Gary] Hey guys.
- [Woman 4] Hi.
- [Gary] Hi.
- [Woman 5] 'Sup Gary?
- [Gary] Hey. You getting ready?
- [Woman 6] Getting ready.
- [Gary] Packing?
- [Woman 6] Yeah.
- [Man 4] What's going on?
- [Gary] 'Sup dude?
- [Man 4] DRock, love your
work. Oh, hey, you too.
- [Gary] Look how much
shit there's still here.
(DRock groans)
Is she wearing a Bills shirt?
You know what scared me?
Your Bills shirt.
- [Christina] Oh Gary.
- Do you think it's a good idea
to wear Bills shirts
in these parts?
That's a strategic mistake.
No. it's alright I'm just
going in the HR software.
No big deal, just got
to leave a comment.
It's like staggeringly better?
- It's staggeringly different.
- So what? When people sit
there going to like shit
when the ones that
sit close the window.
Everybody sees it?
- All the walls are glass.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- So it's all light.
- It's all light.
- Like when it rains.
- The difference of views,
you have the water,
look down south you look
right over the Highline,
World Trade Center, Statue of Liberty.
- It's game changing.
- I'm also super into we're
there and we're just gonna watch
the whole fucking thing--
- Get built.
- get built.
- Smart.
Matty D. Oh!
Look at this crew.
This is like a family reunion.
- Gentlemen.
- [Gary] It's a family reunion.
This is where you sit?
- Yeah.
My team kicked me out
of our regular desks.
- [Gary] Are you
ready for 12? 12?
You ready for Hudson Yards?
Did you see it?
- I got to see the
seating arrangements.
- But did you physically go?
- No, I'm looking forward to it.
- [Tyler] Sunday night
and set it all up.
We'll move it yeah.
- Yo. What's happening dude?
- Big poppa.
- How you livin'?
- All good? Large.
- Yeah, all good.
- [Woman 7] On 12?
- [Man 5] Whoa.
- [Gary] Well, I figured
I'd come and see 12.
I'm going to miss 12 so much.
We hooked up once.
I hooked up once with 12.
Core?
That's a really good
screensaver, brother.
You might be up for a promotion.
- [Man 6] Whoa. Whoa.
- I can send it to you, too.
- [Gary] I'm firing a
Buffalo Bills fan on 15.
- Good.
- [Woman 8] All right,
we have four minutes.
- [DRock] That's it.
- That's it.
So I just went on floor 16, 15
and 12 with Tyler and DRock and
I will never see
these floors again.
(light music)
Hello.
- [Man 7] What're you doing here?
I'm coming back because my
flight's delayed I'm going to
bang out the last episode of
#AskGaryVee in it's
original location.
On this episode, we do
the last episode ever of
The #AskGaryVee Show
in this office.
You guys don't seem
to be contributing.
You guys seem to be
working really hard on the move.
- We go started early.
- [Gary] Got it.
We just started the move though.
- We're already done.
- [Gary] Got it. Okay. Alright.
Can you call and find out
with the fuck is going on?
- Okay.
- Fuck me.
Oh, fuck me.
This flight pisses
me off so bad.
What are we doing with
this fucking flight?
They just cancel
the flight outright?
They push me to tomorrow?
There's a major storm I guess
in Nashville so everything's,
my flight has been flat out
cancelled rebooked for tomorrow.
We'll hang here for 10,
15 two minutes, maybe.
- [Driver] Sure, sir.
- There might be chance we're
going back and we'll
go in the morning.
That's why DailyVee is so cool.
Captures the highs and the lows
of high-class business problems.
Listen, not every plan works out
the way you think it's going to.
Nashville, don't worry
I will never let anybody down.
Unfortunately, tomorrow morning
I have a 5:45 flight
middle seat economy.
Connecting.
It's going to be a
tough day tomorrow.
Epic day, iconic day.
Moving offices for the
one, two, three,
four, five, sixth office.
BuddyMedia conference room,
Sunshine Suites, 23rd St.,
24th St., 27th St., 24th St.
and now Hudson Yards.
Back to where we
started west side.
(hip hop music)